[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
17 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire où l'on discute des sujets
qui font l'actualité
améliorer la circulation curité fut
édifiée la circulation des communique
les noises ont fait le choix ces dix
dernières années de passer à 30
kilomètres avant totalité ou en grande
partie qu'elle bitton peut-on en tirer
on en parle avec nos invités jean mas
jean-baptiste à monique bonsoir bonsoir
êtes le maire de villepreux marque
lartigau bonsoir bonsoir êtes conseiller
municipal délégué au plan communal de la
circulation pour la ville de poissy et
daniel guerreau bonsoir bonjour vous
êtes président de 40 millions
d'automobilistes et je vais commencer
avec vous monsieur lartigau puisque
poitiers c'est la dernière ville à avoir
généralisé dans les yvelines et 30
km/heure qu'est ce qui a poussé la
commune a passé cette mesure alors en
fait on a fait un diagnostic de des
différentes limitations de vitesse qui
existait sur poissy dans un premier
temps on voulait travailler
exclusivement sur le centre-ville sur
nos zones commerçantes et on s'est très
vite aperçu que dans l'ensemble de nos
quartiers on avait beaucoup de
limitations de vitesse différentes et
déjà on avait déjà beaucoup de tronçons
de rues qui était à 30 km heure ou 40 km
heure d'autres zones
à 20 km heure on avait des zones à 50 et
on s'est donc aperçu que il y avait un
manque de lisibilité pour les
conducteurs et avec nos travaux urbains
qui arrivent des notamment le tramway
on a pris la décision qui ont s'est
aperçu qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus
simple finalement de passer l'ensemble
de la vie la zone 30 j'ai choisi
d'uniformiser on a choisi d'uniformiser
tout à fait puisqu'on a des aménagements
qui arrivent encore et même les
boulevards où on aurait pu laisser à 50
bientôt il y aura des aménagements qui
vont nous obliger à passer à 30 km/heure
notamment des écoles où comme je le
disais le tramway jambes et sista monica
villepreux la mesure est mise en place
en 2010 neuf c'est votre prédécesseur
qui le décide mais votre conseil
municipal n'est pas revenu sur la
décision vous y voyez des bains des
bienfaits
oui vous avez effectivement ça a été mis
en place sous la précédente mandature
par nos prédécesseurs vous l'avez
rappelé moi je j'estime nous estimons
avec les élus bbox et une c'était une
bonne décision et qu'on a aujourd'hui
aucune raison de revenir dessus
il faut rappeler peut-être la
philosophie à ce moment là de deux
pourquoi cette mesure des 30 km/heure
généraliser la ville preuve il est
d'abord un enjeu de sécurité évidemment
un enjeu de sécurisation et ça a été dit
par le collègue de poissy aussi aux
abords des écoles dans une ville où on
se déplace encore en voiture il y avait
un enjeu également et ça a été dit aussi
d'harmonisation de la vitesse sur la
ville à la fois pour un hors-jeu de
visibilité un hors-jeu de compréhension
et puis aussi je trouve que c'est une
bonne alternative à la piétonnisation
qui peut être pertinente à certains
endroits notamment sur sur un centre
ville mais moi je suis plutôt opposés à
la piétonnisation à outrance et
généralisé donc je trouve que le 30 km
heure est un bon est avant juste milieu
pour pouvoir équilibres moi ce que je
constate surtout c'est qu'à l'époque
nous avions des excès de vitesse le 50
km a été assez largement
dépassé est peu respectée et finalement
on le voit aujourd'hui quand on a ces
trois kilomètres avant vivre un des
objectifs c'est quand même d'avoir une
vitesse évidemment en dessous les 30
kilomètres heure mais qui se situe entre
30 et 40 km heure donc c'est de diminuer
la vitesse de 10 à 15 km heure dans os
concurrents même de la ville et puis
après je reviendrai peut-être en tout
cas sur
des avancées que cela peut comporter
notamment sur des projets en termes de
vélo de plan vélo qu'on se développer
sur la commune je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
on a une une acculturation en tout cas
des habitudes qui ont été prises avec
ses 30 km/heure depuis trois ans
maintenant qu'ils nous permettent
d'envisager de nouveaux projets de
nouveaux modes de déplacements qui sont
beaucoup plus beaucoup plu sera en tout
cas on arrive à aborder ces sujets là de
façon beaucoup plus sereine parce que
des habitudes ont été prises en tout cas
moi je vois dans ma commune et géo la
vraie tout à l'heure avec quelques
données chiffrées parce qu'on a fait des
contrôles évidemment que le 30 km heure
et globalement majoritairement en tout
cas respecté et on a plus d'accidents on
note on note évidemment une baisse des
accidents sur la route et sur sur les
voiries communales d'agde hérault vient
d'entendre donc deux communes qui ont
fait ce choix est ce que vous à 40
millions d'automobilistes vous comprenez
c'est volonté des communes alors 40
millions d'automobilistes on n'a rien
contre le 30 km heure bien entendu mais
nous ce que nous disons et ce que nous
disait ce que dis-je la grande majorité
d'automobilistes c'est que c'est la
généralisation qui est un peu gênante
parce que dans la vie pas grave vous
avez des gens qui sont gros ils sont
petits sans viendrait à personne l'idée
de les enfermer dans le même costume
donc là si vous voulez c'est un vrai
problème parce que quand vous regardez
la configuration d'une ville vous avez
des endroits avec des avenues assez
large hélas si vous avez un 30 km heure
si les gens respectent pas ils n'y
arrivent pas à moi j'essayais dans paris
à 7 heures du matin on n'y arrive pas je
ne sais pas tout à fait crédible je
pense que avoir le 50 et le 30 c'est
bien parce que quand vous dit tout à
l'heure j'entendais le maire de poissy
qui disait ça permet que par exemple
contre la prochaine récolte ainsi que
les ex terrain par contre quand vous
êtes à 50 ils voulaient 30 km heure vous
avez une alerte je dis attention danger
je ralentis caen est à 30 partout pas
finalement aux habitués des gens font
rouler attendre c'est pas évident mais
finalement vous n'avez pas d' alerte
rouge est toujours à l'invitation des
pina leur part de leur danger alors
cette fois ci j'ai un ami que
j'interrogeais ce matin il m'a dit moi
ça me gêne pas du tout j'y vais tous les
jours mais j'arrive jamais rouler à 30
puisque les routes et les rues sont
étroites et des voitures de se garer il
ya beaucoup de feu donc c'est pas un
problème alors aux villes proches
connaît moins mais c'est vrai que quand
vous avez une configuration de rues
étroites etc il n'y a pas de souci on
peut mettre 30 on peut mettre peut-être
vinci ça c'est si la configuration là la
rue l'obligent mais pour nous c'est une
question de visibilité quand vous avez
quand les gens comprennent pas quand les
gens sont dans la voiture et qui semble
pas qu'il faut ralentir c'est un vrai
souci
alors ce n'est pas le maire de poissy
qui est avec nos plateaux ses marques
lartigau conseiller municipal en charge
notamment du de la circulation
ces remarques vous les comprenez vous
les avez entendu vous les avez vous vous
y attendiez
on s'y attendait complètement et on les
a étudiées avant de prendre la décision
on n'a pas ça s'est pas fait en un
claquement de doigts on a beaucoup
réfléchi et je rejoins un peu cette idée
de dire que
cette limitation de vitesse à 30 km
heure ne se prête pas forcément à toutes
les communes
il faut déjà faire un diagnostic de ce
qui existe effectivement quand vous avez
des avenues larges avec des trottoirs
larges le piéton est déjà en toute
sécurité peu
peut vaquer à ses occupations et occupé
et occuper l'espace public
à poissy
qui est une ville un peu un peu
anciennes avec très peu de grandes
avenues
on a beaucoup de petites rues des
trottoirs pas forcément très large donc
7 cette généralisation en zone 30 nous
paraissait tout à fait adapté je le
répète c'est pas forcément le cas d'
effectivement de toutes les villes on va
avoir un nouveau boulevard ce qu'on
appelle le boulevard de l'europe qui
permet de contourner tu va permettre de
relier hr à la gare sans passer par la
gare de poissy sans passer par les
quartiers résidentiels
donc ça va être c'est un projet porté
par le département on réfléchit ce
boulevard là qui va être tout neuf avec
ses les trottoirs
assez large on réfléchit à faire un axe
50 voilà pour pas effectivement
pénaliser les automobilistes puisque là
on aura un aménagement 9 qui permettra
de rouler à 50 en toute sécurité aussi
bien pour les piétons que pour les
automobiles aurait fait attention à la
physionomie de la route parce que le
serema le centre d'études et expertise
sur les risques l'environnement la
mobilité et l'aménagement donne quelques
conseils pour la mise en place des 30km
à la cohérence des limitations de
vitesse mais qu'il faut aussi garder des
zones à 50 km à jean baptiste à monica
ville prouesse que vous avez imaginé
revenir sur certaines circulation pour
certaines rues de votre commune
non parce que on a des axes assez
roulant qui traverse la commune
notamment une ancienne départementale
qui est toujours aujourd'hui une voirie
d'intérêt communautaire mais peu importe
sa classification et sa qualification
mais qui qui traverse finalement le
passage pour se rendre au collège donc
encore une fois j'en viens à des enjeux
de sécurité nous ce qu'on a constaté
parce qu'on a évidemment avec la police
municipale
fait des contrôles et essayer de dégager
des statistiques pour tirer un bilan de
cette mesure là
si on prend plusieurs plusieurs endroits
plusieurs localités stratégiques de la
ville nous avons mis à un radar qui
n'enregistre évidemment les passagers
des vitesses qui a d'ailleurs davantage
d'être un radar qu'on ne voit pas dans
le sens où c'est pas un radar
pédagogique qui n'est pas branché il ne
fait pas d'eux de lumière donc s'il
n'est pas de nature à influencer le
comportement de l'automobiliste ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui c'est con à 93% sur
je vous parle d'à peu près cent mille
passages en cumulé donc des données
assez substantiel on à 93% des passages
qui sont
qui respecte des 30 km heure on arrive à
98 quand il s'agit des 40 km/heure et 99
lorsqu'il s'agit des 50 km lorsqu'il me
dire que l'objectif pour moi il est
atteint l'objectif premier
quand on met une vitesse généralisée à
30 km/heure déjà c'est de faire
respecter le 50 et évidemment d'avoir
d'avoir un respect du 30 dans l'absolu
on voit qu on y est donc ça c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt positif et moi j'y vois
aussi pourquoi je
on n'a aucunement envie de revenir sur
cette mesure est là c'est aussi le
vice-président en charge des mobilités
durables à saint quentin qui parle c'est
que moi je pense qu'il faut il faut pas
opposer aujourd'hui autrement dit aux
autres types de mobilité notamment vélo
ou trottinette on a pu d'ailleurs
déployé sur saint quentin en yvelines
mais en revanche dans cette idée de
partage de l'espace public il faut créer
des conditions de sécurité et de confort
pour les différents utilisateurs de la
route est donc aujourd'hui quand on veut
développer la pratique du vélo la
pratique des mobilités douces et
innovante la pratique des mods actif
aussi les circulations piétonnes il faut
évidemment qu'on ait un contrôle un
contrôle de la vitesse alors pour ce
faire il ya plusieurs solutions c'est
vrai que dans des communes comme la
mienne qui sont très contrainte de par
son aménagement on ne peut pas répondre
par des voies cyclables et des des
pistes cyclables systématiquement ça
veut dire qu'on est aussi sur des zones
de rencontre sur les zones partagé entre
différents types de mobilité encore une
fois ça peut se résoudre par 2,7 de la
signalétique ça peut se résoudre par des
aménagements sur la voirie avec des
chicanes votre mais le fait aujourd'hui
d'avoir déjà depuis trois ou quatre ans
c'est 30 km/heure généralisée lorsque on
veut promouvoir de nouveaux types de
mobilité telles que je les décris ce
soir on a une population qui est déjà
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus à l'écouté
qui est en tout cas prête à ce type de
mutation et moi je suis pour
l'accompagnement dans le changement je
pense qu' aucun changement mais bon est
favorable quand il est subi nos
concertée et qu'il arrive un peu comme
un coup de massue du duo vert vers le
bas
cette mesure des 30 km heure avait été
concertée et aujourd'hui on avance
maintenant dans déploiement d'un plan
vélo communal qui va d'ailleurs
s'insérer dans le schéma directeur
cyclable de l'agglomération
c'est aussi une demande forte de la part
de nos concitoyens et le fait encore une
fois d'être déjà en zone trente
généralisé sur l'ensemble de la libre
permet d'avoir des conditions propices à
soi
danic héros une réaction aux propos de
ces deux élus je crois que la proche de
poissy me paraît assez cohérente dans le
monsieur monsieur casser ça dit qu'on va
réétudier on va regarder les rues qui
sont larges pour pouvoir garder les 55
paraît tout à fait cohérent quant à eux
chamanique je comprends qu'ils aient du
mal à revenir en arrière c'est
extrêmement compliqué de revenir en
arrière quand on a une mesure où les
gens sont un peu habitué je crois que
c'est complètement compliqué ceci dit il
faut faire attention aussi à ne pas
dégoûter les gens de venir dans votre
ville quand on voit madame hidalgo qui
dit moi j'aime et transua battra pas ce
que je veux il s'en passe en vélo donc
voilà on a aussi ce sentiment qu'on veut
rejeter la voiture et nous on est moi je
suis non
pardon si c'est évidemment ça venir le
vide est donc scellé il ya plusieurs
approches crois qu'il faut pas leur
poids si c'est quand même la ville de
l'automobile on comprend qu'ils n'ont
pas envie de décourager les
automobilistes parce qu'autrement leurs
usines ne tournent plus et monsieur veut
dire pour jeu son approche me paraît
bien expliquer bien cohérente ya
peut-être que sur les voies
qui sont des oies assez large
on pourrait peut-être
laissé 50 km/heure ce qu'après il ya
preuve de respect à tous les quelques
lecointe effet à paris on voit que ça le
premier mois il ya eu 1 km heure de
moins de vitesse alors c'est pas
extraordinaire quand je pense que cette
mesure c'est plutôt parfois de
l'affichage
alors il ya une chose qu'on n'a pas
abordé aussi il faut savoir que c'est
une aberration écologique parce que
quand vous voulez mais c'était dans la
dentelle prochaine partie on était
vraiment sur les sur d'armor l'aspect
sécuritaire qui est souvent le premier
élément à portel monsieur a mené que
vous souhaitiez réagir oui
bon pour monsieur joaquín qui est je ne
lui en tiens pas rigueur évidemment mais
qui connaît peut-être voir la commune de
wimereux on est sûr n'est sur une
commune d'un peu plus de dix mille
habitants on va les deux départementales
qui
ne traverse pas la commune donc ils sont
des axes le roulant qui permettent
ensuite de pénétrer la commune donc
évidemment c'est départementales sont
par définition non concernés par les 30
km heure après on a très peu de voirie
large on est sur des voies win qui sont
des routes qui sont très étroites
d'ailleurs avec des pièces d'habitation
qui ne permettent pas souvent de
d'accueillir les véhicules des
particuliers donc on a aussi du
stationnement sur les trottoirs et sur
l'espace public mais sans pouvoir
débattre longuement cycle de toute façon
on n'a pas de dax majoritairement
roulant qui permettrait de gagner du
temps sur des temps de parcours donc
pour nous en tout cas par rapport à la
typologie du territoire de villepreux
qu'on ne pourrait évidemment pas
comparer à paris et je rejoins ce qui a
été dit sur sur la ville de paris où je
crois que couper paris du reste de l'île
de france avec ces mesures très
restrictive et parfois au prix de
belgique qui ne font pas sens on est
évidemment loin de ça sur la commune de
litres
de poissy souhaité réagir
non non je revois mon collègue de de
villepreux effectivement
on nous a souvent taxé
deal hidalgo g10 et la ville de poissy
notre réflexion
est menée
bien antérieurement à aux annonces
faites par madame hidalgo est
effectivement
c'est pas ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
toutes les villes ne peuvent pas passer
à 30 km ont fait cela avec monsieur
monique de garder ou de mettre en place
de par la physionomie de vos ennemis
tout à fait et je hais je rejoins
monsieur perrault à paris moi qui s'y
qui circulent toute l'année en ile de
france à paris il ya des axes c'est une
aberration mais ils sont en train d'un
peu de revenir en arrière parce qu'il ya
des êtres qui repasse à 50 km déjà alors
nous a atterrés 78 on a été dans vos
villes à poissy à villepreux tâter un
peu le terrain écouter ce que disent vos
administrés moi ça me va me va pour
éviter qu on retrouve vite parce qu'il
ya du monde pour la sécurité de tout le
monde sait bien je pense que c'est une
bonne chose surtout pour les enfants les
piétons s'il y avait beaucoup d'enfants
qu'ils ont été renversés en peu de temps
et je trouve que ça c'est très bien si
les gens pouvaient la respecte et
d'ailleurs c'est pas toujours le cas
malheureusement franchement c'est très
compliqué surtout quand on a des gosses
et c'est là qu'il faut aller chercher
non mais là on se retrouve à prendre
quarante minutes sur une petite route ça
il a été avant mais maintenant avec les
30 km c'est encore pire même quand
c'était lié limité à 50 je roulais
tranquillement je roulais prudemment
parce que les rues les routes sont assez
étroites et des voitures garées un peu
partout c'est un peu étroit du qu'il
faut s'adapter
finalement on retrouve un petit peu les
arguments qu'on assure sur ce plateau à
poissy ce que vos cours sortie c'est
pour le moment le peut-être le manque de
respect de cette mesure oui tout à fait
c'est une mesure qui est assez récente
on a pour le moment effectué aucun
contrôle
on voulait que
que nos citoyens nos concitoyens et ce
aussi nos vielles nos citoyens les
citoyens des villes voisines qui
traverse énormément poissy
prennent conscience de la chose il va on
va commencer à mettre en place des
contrôles radars pédagogiques on va
faire de la pédagogie avec des petits
flyers ce qu'ils vont être distribués
pour expliquer l'intérêt des 30 km heure
et puis après on passera on
passera à la sanction mais
il faut alors il ya un de nous de nos
pisciacais qui disait qui prenait 40
minutes tout ça ça c'est pas les
histoires des 30 km heure où des 50 ou
des 70 c'est à dire que c'est une heure
de pointe et malheureusement il ya des
gars certains matins ou soirées où
certaines soirées où effectivement pour
traverser la ville de poissy on met plus
d'une demi heure mais ça c'est dû aux
flux de véhicules et c'est pas du tout
lié aux limitations de vitesse parce que
je voudrais
en profiter pour
pour revenir sur une idée qui est un peu
fausse de dire on perd du temps etc il
faut juste savoir que sur de
passer de 50 à 30 km heure on perd que
10 % sur un trajet donc un trajet vous
faisiez enfants en dix minutes vous
allez mettre onze minutes pour le faire
donc et par rapport aux bénéfices
sécuritaire que ça apporte puisqu'il
faut que le chiffre qui est quand même
important à retenir ces cas
30 km heure un choc en train de piéton
et un automobiliste
vous avez quand même neuf fois moins de
risque que cet accident soit mortel donc
10 % de temps de trajet en plus pour
pour un risque minime de mortalité je
pense que l'équation est vite fait oui
et puis il ya la distance de freinage
aussi fait deux fois moins importante
qu'à 50 km heure on est à 13 m contre 27
je voulais ce que le temps file
comparses un petit peu du côté de
l'enviro de l'impact environnemental
vous allez avait soulevé monsieur perron
il ya quelques secondes en faisant des
recherches pour moment il n'y a pas
d'impact
qui le met en avant les effets positifs
ou négatifs de ce fait puisque le fait
de rouler à 30 km à poulies en effet
beaucoup plus qu'à 50 km ha mais souvent
la fluidification du trafic compte
rencontre bat lancerait cet effet du
côté de 40 millions d'automobilistes
vous avez fait des tests aussi pour
cette notion-là
l'on sait c'est à poissy honda le savoir
dans la ville de l'automobile c'est
qu'un moteur thermique quand ils moi
j'étais motoriste 1 quand j'étais tout
jeune et à 30 km heure on pollue
tellement plus qu'à 50 km heure la
vitesse optimale pour une automobile
pour polluer le moins possible sur le
cours de 70 à 80 donc plus on baisse des
vitesses plus on pollue alors après moi
j'ai on n'a pas fait de test mais on
s'aperçoit vous parlez de fluidifier
mais quand on sera lente et les voitures
c'est un peu compliqué le flux édifié
donc ça a un impact
certain au niveau 2 de commandes des
émissions donc je crois qu'il faut faire
très attention donc c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qui est qui est parfait
tranquille nos maisons mais j'ai quand
même du mal à
contredire ces deux élus qui ont le sens
des responsabilités on voit très bien
qu'ils sont dans le bon sens plutôt que
dans l'idéologie on n'est pas habitué à
faire des débats avec des maires ou des
collectivités on a surtout des débats
avec la ville de paris où la ville de
lyon où des gens comme toi qui t'y
mettre d'abord l'idéologie avant le bon
sens et là je trouve que c'est pas du
tout le cas nous avons un maire de
wimereux et un élu ou un responsable de
poissy qui privilégie le bon sens si
l'on parlait de de pédagogie donc voilà
s'il faut aller dans ce sens là ce qui
irrite les automobilistes c'est quand
ils se font prendre parce qu'ils ont et
jean pas pu respecter parce que la
configuration de la route ne les
interdisait pas de rouler un peu plus
vite donc je crois que pédagogie
responsabiliser on perd pas beaucoup de
temps c'est vrai en roulant 30 km heure
mais quand c'est aborder avec le bon
sens moi je n'ai pas grand chose à dire
les automobistes d'ailleurs mon ami qui
j'avais ce matin qui est un membre de
carlos de régime à dix mois après si
jamais de problème j'arrive pas à rouler
à 30 à la configuration de la ville fait
que je peux pas rouler à tournoyer
après le fait aussi de passer à 30 km
heure les chaussées passe en double sens
cette fois pour les cyclistes monsieur
monique la soulever pour la ville de
ville promet aussi pour saint quentin en
yvelines à poissy est ce qu'on cherche
aussi à développer les mobilités douces
et avant donner un petit peu le tout
voiture alors on essaye c'est pas
évident parce que on n'a pas forcément
les largeurs de voix suffisantes
avec le tramway on espère que on va
pouvoir développer un vrai réseau on y
travaille en tout cas je pense que
passer la ville à 30 km heure c'est la
première étape indispensable
comme disait monsieur à monique
donc on y pense après
on a pris un arrêté pour passer la ville
en zone 30 on a appris en parallèle un
arrêté pour que toutes les rues en sens
unique
qui n'était pas encore
accessible aux cyclistes en sens inverse
ne le devienne pas parce qu'on a des
rues en sens unique
comme je disais très peu large et si on
les cyclistes commencent à remonter
toutes les rues en sens unique
je pense qu'on va avoir une augmentation
des accidents assez considérable donc on
a pris un arrêté municipal dans ce sens
là mais à vil prix aussi monsieur le
maire vous voyez des modifications c'est
des comportements outre le fait que les
automobilistes lèvent le pied est ce que
les gens vont peut-être déposer leurs
enfants à l'école à pied en trottinette
à vélo plutôt que de prendre la voiture
pour faire 300 mètres parfois oui on
rejoint cette idée d'accompagner le
changement c'est à dire que les
pratiques évoluent mais il faut à
présent les alternatives
ce que ne fait pas du tout alors je suis
la mère de paris doit avoir les oreilles
qui sifflent avec notre territoire mais
je trouve que c'est ce qui manque
effectivement à paris on n'a pas
d'alternative notamment de transports en
commun de parkings relais suffisant pour
pouvoir rejoindre de bari laisser sa
voiture aux portes de paris et ensuite
poursuivre ses déplacements au sein de
laquelle qui tablent aujourd'hui à
l'épreuve c'est pas les mêmes enjeux
mais on a déployé une offre de
trottinettes alors qu'ils touchent les
plus jeunes évidemment on a une ligne de
bus qui est en train d'être prolongée on
a évidemment aussi un plan de
circulation que nous sommes en train de
définir et qui va aboutir au premier
semestre 2022 qui va comporter un volet
important je me disais ce plan vélo est
d'ailleurs l'impact finalement
environnementale et écologique parce que
on peut avoir une volonté politique très
forte sur l'environnement et sur nos
logiciels et sur l'écologie c'est notre
cas sans forcément avoir de l'idéologie
derrière monsieur qui roule à 10 avec de
la recherche du bon sens mais le vrai
impact environnemental il est là c'est à
dire que quand vous avez créer des
conditions propices en réduisant la
vitesse dans notre cas avec le 30 km à
réaliser à villepreux vous avez préparé
les mentalités vous avez participé à une
évolution des pratiques qui font
qu'aujourd'hui la population est prête à
être avec des zones de rencontre avec
des zones partager avec un espace encore
une fois que l'espace public alors
partage de l'espace public est propice à
d'autres types de mobilité qui elles
sont plus propres qui elles sont plus
durables donc pour répondre à votre
question oui on a une vraie demande très
forte d'un maillage cyclable au sein de
la commune pour des déplacements à vélo
nous on a davantage sur un peu comme une
commande autres d'avoir les commerces
d'avoir les établissements scolaires
d'avoir les gymnases à proximité donc
évidemment que quelque part on gagne
presque plus en temps de parcours en se
rendant d'une commodité stratégique à
une autre en vélo ou à trottinette ou
piéton en cheminement piéton parce que
parce que tout est à proximité mais il
faut pouvoir le faire et encore une fois
je crois qu'on est trop mot c'est la
sécurité il faut que l'ensemble des
utilisateurs de la route quel qu'il soit
se sentent en sécurité
il ya la notion de confort aussi
derrière il ya la notion d'art hier
après en troisième plan de temps de
parcours pour que évidemment chacun
puisse continuer à circuler librement
sans prendre trop de retard sur ses
déplacements mais voilà je me sens une
évolution des mentalités
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je ne
reviens pas sur cette mesure mais avait
été elle et elle est la bienvenue parce
que ça nous permet aujourd'hui d'aller
plus loin et finalement quand on va
avancer sur le vélo c'est ce qui est
aussi nous permettra d'avoir un impact
écologique important donc l'un dans
l'autre c'est bénéfique pour tout le
monde nous ferons donc un bilan dans
trois ans pour voir si poissy a le même
retour que ville proche je propose qu'on
s'arrête sur ces mots merci à tous les
trois d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau temps d'échangé d'ici là
bien sûr prenez soin de vous
il
[Musique]